hello guys I'm Ryan right cyber we're
gonna check out today the Just Cause 3 I
always want to say just cut just cut
it's cuz three-story trailer it's kind
of like the Toy Story 3 - ok that's not
even close yeah anyway we're gonna check
this out yeah let's do this
rated M for Mature thank you I never
really thought about people but there is
a difference between you and you see
look at me - chief she's beautiful she's
a jewel in the song but you see Medici
she's completely rotten
albeit stump the ultimate power
you see Sebastian Obi Rebello was
sitting on a ton of a berry which makes
him the agency's best goddamn friend the
very who can be refined into powder to
exclusive or almost benefits few stories
in their own hands you're going to
change that I got the clap
you've got to show the people we can
take back to their cities of
to be just another baby
chaos and destruction and when he comes
to attack the insignificant until his
friend the devil still of defunding
nothing
my games cannot touch what do you plan
on
it's not subtle at all set the world on
fire claimed that game looks like a
blasty blast I want to just [ __ ] up the
world right now but in like a way that
makes sense
not like Grand Theft Auto were you just
like hurt people I want to do it where
you're like yeah I'm surrounded by bad
guys in this open world [ __ ] up a bunch
of bags do you see how many explosions
were in that trailer yeah it was like a
Michael Bay game true and that for some
reason I feel like that's still not
enough explosions yeah like I'd be like
I'm gonna get more out of the game it's
funny they call it a story trailer one
it was more of just like a crazy I
didn't believe in grass the story
actually because I was so enamored by it
there's a lot to absorb right right
there
in terms of visual aspects that's the
thing with videogames is like you get so
pulled into the visual aspect that you
start studying it that you might miss
some of what's actually being said
mm-hmm you know kind of like porn no you
ever like dragged off to a porno and
you're like I don't even know what's
going on in this porno I need to go back
and then listen to dude I'm so you stop
and then you watch it with a critical
ideas back on mm-hm
because that's what really gets you into
it we've been stuck on the game since we
first started seeing the trailers of all
the sorts of [ __ ] we're about to explode
and this just continues to cement that
idea of like we're gonna blow so much
[ __ ] up and it's not gonna be subtle
whatsoever yeah yeah it was like
something subtle
the main guy looks like if Drake from
uncharted and Shia LaBeouf had a baby
and they came out with a sexy accent no
that was actually a speech impediment
but it turned out sexy but it turned out
all right boy came out on test the first
male and male
no procreation and one of the resulting
mutations from yeah is the speech
impediment which made it sound like a
sexy foreigner or whatever country this
is in Mexico Colombia I'm glad that
Waterloo paid no I don't know Cuba Jorge
I was reading this article with Zack
Snyder talking about Man of Steel and
the destruction that happens at the end
of the movie yeah
when the hero is trying to save the day
by killing the bad guy but oh yeah and
he blows everything the [ __ ] out yeah
yeah that's kind of what this game
reminds yeah we gotta kill the bad guy
but we're gonna destroy everything Hey
look I saw oil rigs I saw him like
military structures I didn't see like
you know but mall that's true that's
that's fair that's fair it's not still
he's not as bad as Superman
look you know the janitor didn't wake up
that morning same way I'm feeling
especially evil I don't think I'm gonna
clean up floor - today was very general
like the trailer I found one critique on
it is that it was generic trailer music
with generic edits and cuts and
explosions and something we've seen over
and over again but doesn't change my
opinion about like wanting the game yeah
it looks like a blast but it they call
it a story trailer and I know a thank
you some cooler like cinematic [ __ ] to
go on yeah well I mean basically all
they said it was going to be is like
that the dictator was like we're gonna
lure him out with like innocence and
he's gonna show up and when he comes to
save the day we killed his friends like
okay just like Mattos a movie oh my god
just causes just feels like just cause
it's not the game that I'm really like
into doing this story for I'm more like
I'm gonna blow [ __ ] up that's all it's
been like up until now is like check out
all the [ __ ] you're gonna be exploding
this is more story than previous games
but you don't buy like plants vs.
zombies for it's incredible in-depth
storyline you do it because you want to
shoot zombies with plants this analogy
sucks let's move on dude plants vs.
zombies was like the thing that led me
on a spiritual path to finding God the
peace you two really spoke to you huh
yeah that and duck on that anyway guys
thanks for tuning in to the channel if
you're new to it you can subscribe today
and become a reject ah who azzam reject
oi reject door gasm reject orgasm reject
your orgasm just hold it in and contain
it that way when you can't control it
anymore it feels that much better check
out dansgaming channel where he plays
games on the gaming channel become a
cyber cyber nitwit today No
Mike Rivera of course of Al of a shout
out from the real rejects crew yeah I
have to say ever since I subscribe to
the real rejects I've become a huge fan
of reaction channels no just watch ours
you dick right and the rest of the crew
have some of the best reaction of videos
I've ever seen yeah keep going strong on
posting videos and I see you our fan of
Red Hot Chili Peppers oh the band yeah
it's a little big fan Ryan they are my
favorite band they're my favorite band
you explain I was talking about that
with a guy in the sauna today it's
always awkward having a conversation
with the guy in the sauna - you don't
know like you a Veronica I'm a musician
as well check out our band from North
Carolina everyone check out the band
upon the wake they have a Facebook page
Mike Rivera is one of those sexy band
members you just want he looks like Dan
if dance turned into a serial killer boy
he looks like you if you this serial
killer if you turn into a serial killer
this would be know what it looks like
serial killer damn I mean I don't know
whether to be insulted babe come here
for one second just you don't have to be
in front of the camera just look at this
just tell me if this looks like serial
killer no we haven't
that was another guy who looked like a
serial you through the beat I mean
should I be insulted I'm trying to tell
you Dan is it doesn't take much to make
you look like a serial killer